what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today um i have a
special guest on the channel
on the series that i call conversations
with a feminist
hey guys
um okay so guys you already know the
deal i show feminist jordan peterson and
i get their reaction
so um before i start you're gonna
introduce introduce yourself to the
people tell them where to find you um my
name is adeline you can just find me on
instagram at the line q301 i think
that's all i'm really active on okay
so today we're gonna be watching jordan
peterson
and this man is a psychologist and i'm
gonna just give you a little little
background on him okay so he got in
trouble because he was against a law
that used trans pronouns
that the law said that you had to use
trans pronouns
and so um
what happened was he he's very polite
he's a very nice guy
but he refuse he doesn't think the
government can tell you what you can and
cannot say
okay i see does that make sense i
transfer pronouns as in like
calling a trans person the gender that
they currently are yeah
sorry he's talking to you yeah so
basically if i if i wanted to be called
he
the the law would basically say that you
must call someone he
and and he didn't he just disagreed with
you can't tell someone what they can and
cannot say
okay i see that's quite controversial
what do you think i'm i
think that's a bit wild but i could kind
of understand where he's coming from
yeah
but it's i think respectfully you should
i just address them as what they want to
be addressed as yeah yeah and that's
kind of what he said but he just didn't
agree with like the law so
but that's illegal
oh
yeah so then he decided that he was
going to write a self-help book for men
and he went on this show to be
interviewed
but that that is what put him on the map
and made him famous was being against
that law jordan peterson you've said
that men need to quote grow the hell up
tell me why
well because there's nothing
uglier than an old infant
there's nothing good about it
people who don't grow up don't find the
sort of meaning in their life that
sustains them through difficult times
and they're certain to encounter
difficult times
and they're left bitter and resentful
and without purpose and adrift and
hostile and resentful and vengeful and
arrogant and deceitful and and of no use
to themselves and of no use to anyone
else and no partner for a woman and
there's nothing in it that's good so you
say i mean that sounds pretty bad you're
saying the crisis of masculinity i mean
what do you do about it
you
tell
you help people understand why
it's necessary and important for them to
grow up and adopt responsibility why
that isn't uh shake your finger and get
your act together sort of thing why it's
more like what why it's more like
a delineation of the kind of destiny
that makes life worth living i've been
telling young men and but it's not i
wasn't specifically aiming this message
at young men to begin with it just kind
of turned out that way and it's mostly
you admit it's mostly men listening i
mean it is
your audiences well it's about 80 on in
on youtube which is a
youtube is a male domain primarily so
it's hard to tell how much of it is
because youtube is male and how how much
of it is because of what i'm saying
but um
you you what i've been telling young men
is that there's an actual reason why
they need to grow up which is that they
have something to offer you know that
that that people have within them this
capacity to set the world straight and
that's necessary to manifest in the
world and that also doing so
is where you find the meaning that
sustains you in life so what's gone
wrong then oh god all sorts of things
have gone wrong i think that
i don't think that young men are
hear words of encouragement some some of
them never in their entire lives as far
as i can tell that's what they tell me
and the fact that the words that i've
been that i've been speaking the youtube
lectures that i've done and put online
for example have had such a dramatic
impact is an indication that
young men are starving for this sort of
message because like why in the world
would they have to derive it from a
lecture on youtube
now they're not being taught that they
that it's important to develop yourself
but does it does it bother you that your
audience is predominantly
male does that isn't isn't that a bit
divisive no i don't think so i mean
it's no more divisive than the fact that
youtube is primarily male and tumblers
female isn't it tumblr is primarily
female
but you're just saying that's the way it
is well it's i'm not saying anything
it's just an observation that that's the
way it is um there's plenty of women
that are watching my lectures and coming
to my talks and buying my books it's
just that the majority of them happen to
be men
uh it's what's in it for the women
though
well what sort of partner do you want
do you want an overgrown child
or do you want someone to contend with
that's going to help you and that's rely
on women have some sort of duty to sort
of help fix the crisis of masculinity it
depends on what they want
no i mean it's it's exactly exactly how
i laid it out like
women want
deeply want men who are competent and
powerful
and and i don't mean power in in the in
the in that they can exert tyrannical
control over others that's not power
that's just corruption
power is competence
and why in the world would you not want
a competent partner well
what do you think he's raising some
serious points i kind of agree with what
he's saying yeah
what do you do you think women want
competent partners
a lot of women majority do i can't speak
for all women but
from what i've seen
yeah is there anything you said so far
you disagree with
um
not just yet but i feel like it's
leading to that yeah that he's
introduced women it's about to get a bit
wild okay
well i i know why actually you can't
dominate a competent power partner so if
you want me you should dominate is that
what you're saying no i'd say women who
have had their relationships impaired
with
impaired
their relationships with men
impaired and who are afraid of such
relationships will settle for a weak
partner because they can dominate them
but it's a sub-optimal solution do you
think a lot of women are doing
i think there's a substantial minority
of women who do that and i think it's
very bad for them they're very unhappy
it's very bad for their partners
although their partners get the
advantage of not having to take any
responsibility but what gives you the
right to say that i mean maybe that's
how women want their relationships those
women i mean you're making these vast
generalizations i'm a clinical
psychologist right so you're saying
you've done your research and women are
unhappy dominating men
i didn't say they were unhappy
dominating men i said it was a bad
long-term solution okay you said it was
making them miserable yes it is and it
depends on the time frame i mean there
can be there's intense pleasure in
momentary domination that's why people
do it all the time
but it's no formula for a long-term
successful long-term relationship that's
reciprocal right any long-term
relationship is reciprocal virtually by
definition
so
let me put a quote to you from the book
where you say there are whole
disciplines in universities forthrightly
hostile towards men these are the areas
of study dominated by the post-modern
stroke neo-marxist claim that western
culture in particular is an oppressive
structure created by white men to
dominate and exclude women
but then i want to put minorities too
dominating okay
but i want to put to you that here in
the uk for example let's take that as an
example the gender pay gap stands at
just over nine percent
you've got women at the bbc recently
saying that the broadcaster is illegally
paying them less than men to do the same
job you've got only seven women running
the top ftse 100 companies yeah so it
seems to a lot of women that they're
still being dominated and excluded to
quote your words back to you it does
seem that way but
multivariate analysis of the pay gap
indicate that it doesn't exist
but that's just true is it i mean that's
nine percent kept pay gap that's a gap
between median hourly earnings between
men and women but that exists yeah but
there's multiple reasons for that one of
them is gender but it's not the only
reason like if you're a social scientist
worth worth your salt you never do a
univariate analysis
like you say well women
in aggregate are paid less than men okay
well then we break it down by age we
break it down by occupation we break it
down by interest we break it down by
personality but you're saying basically
it doesn't matter if women aren't
getting to the top because that's what's
skewing that gender pay gap isn't it
you're saying well that's just a factor
you're going to get to the top no i'm
not saying it doesn't matter either
you're saying there are multiple reasons
for it yeah but those reasons why why
should women put up with those reasons
why should women be content i'm not
saying that they should have put up with
it i'm saying that the claim that the
wage gap between men and women is only
due to sex is wrong and it is wrong
there's no doubt about that the
multivariate analysis have been done
well i can give you
multivariate analysis
i'm saying that nine percent pay gap
exists that's a gap between men and
women i'm not saying why it exists but
it exists now if you're a woman that
seems pretty unfair
you have to say why it exists but do you
agree that it's unfair if you're a woman
not necessarily and on average you're
getting paid 9 less than a man that's
not fair is it
it depends on why it's happening
okay what do you think
i feel like she is putting a lot of
words in his mouth like he's not even
being given an opportunity to actually
explain himself and she's already
jumping to conclusions saying well
it's because you don't want to side with
women but he hasn't exactly
implied that
but so far he's still making sense to me
yeah well it's interesting because you
you kind of thought before my show right
you thought that the wage gap existed
right because of sex
yeah
yeah like he said i think it's because
i'm viewing it and
like just based on gender
yeah well it's okay i think we're taught
that from a young age i think a lot of
girls think that
yes basically like due to experience as
well because i already mentioned in the
um podcast the other day because i mean
about the situation where oh with the
dishwasher
hours yeah yeah
but that's my personal experience i
guess i should speak for everyone in the
world yeah
but it's interesting because like when
you when you always hear disparities in
the media right you never think about
like the other factors yes like for
example i forgot what there were two
groups in the u.s where there's a very
big income disparity right and they were
saying why is there this big income
disparity and it turns out one group had
an older population so they're of course
going to have more money because they're
older yeah and it's like a lot of times
i think the media tries to like control
us by saying
like like in this case take pitting us
against men yeah that's true okay i see
and when like anyone that's in the
sciences knows that there's a million
reasons for a disparity
here i can give you an example
okay
there's a personality trait known as
agreeableness
agreeable people are compassionate and
polite
and agreeable people get paid less than
just less agreeable people for the same
job
women are more agreeable than men
again a vast generalization
that's true but that's right and some
women get paid more than men
so you were saying that by and large
women are too agreeable to get the pay
rises now i'm saying that that's one
component
of a multivariate equation that predicts
um salary
it accounts for maybe five percent of
the variance something like that so
surely you need about another twenty
about another eighteen factors one of
which is gender and there is prejudice
there's no doubt about that but it
accounts for a much smaller proportion
of the variance in the pay gap than the
radical feminists claim okay so rather
than denying the pay gap exists which is
what you did at the beginning of this
conversation shouldn't you say to women
rather than being agreeable and not
asking for a pay rise go and ask for a
pay right make yourself disagreeable
with your book oh definitely there's
that but i also didn't deny it existed i
denied it it existed because of gender
okay because i'm very very very
careful with my words
so the pay gap exists you accept that
but you're saying
i mean the pay gap between men and women
exists but you're saying it's not
because of gender it's because women are
too agreeable to ask for pay rises so
one of the reasons okay one of the
reasons so why not get them to ask for a
pay rise i've done that
many many times in my career and they
just counseled oh they do it all the
time you can it's so one of the things
that you do as a clinical psychologist
is um assertiveness training
so you might say
often you treat people for anxiety you
treat them for depression
um and you and maybe the next most
common category after that would be
assertiveness training and so i've had
many many women extraordinarily
competent women in my clinical and
consulting practice and we put together
strategies for their career development
that involve continual pushing competing
for higher wages and often tripled their
wages within a five-year period
of course so
do you actually do you agree that you
would be happy
if that pay gap was eliminated
completely because that's all the
radical feminists are saying it would
depend on how it was eradicated and how
the how how the disappearance of it was
measured and you're saying the cost of
men that's a problem oh there's all
sorts of things that it could be at the
cost of it could even be at the cost of
women's own interests
so because they might not be happy if
they get equal pay
no because it might interfere with other
things that are causing the pay gap that
women are choosing today like having
children
well or choosing careers that actually
happen to be paid less which women do a
lot of but why shouldn't women have the
right to choose not to have children or
the right to choose those demanding
yeah that's fine but you're saying that
makes them unhappy by and large i'm
saying that that no i'm not saying that
i'm i and i actually haven't said that
so far you're saying it makes them
miserable no i said that what was making
them miserable was having part was
having weak partners
that makes them miserable right
she is
constantly putting words in his mouth
i'm struggling to even
sympathize with her
wow
no she it's like she i think because she
didn't like him for the trans stuff
yeah she already like has this image
that he's a bad person and she's just
trying to make him out to be the bad guy
and then he's like counter-attacking
every single time well because he's
smarter than her
like he knows more his points are valid
as well
so
uh was there anything he said so far you
disagree with
um what did he say he must have said um
can't even remember he said something
about
um
i actually actually forgot was it about
weak partners possibly
oh no he said something like about all
women are agreeable
no he didn't say that he said they tend
to be more agreeable
i feel like
it's the way he was when she said he was
generalizing i think he should just
choose his words
wisely and not to say like most
yeah she kind of okay he did clear that
up so i think that's all right
but
if he was to generalize and say every
single woman on the planet is agreeable
i would have been like
no he doesn't we'll see even more that
makes them miserable right um i would
say that many women around the age of i
would say between 28 and 32 have about
how old are you 20 20. okay your
family crisis that they have to deal
with and i think that's partly because
of the foreshortened time frame that
women have to contend with like women
have to get the major pieces of their
life put together faster than men which
is also partly why men aren't under so
much pressure to grow up so because for
the typical woman um she has to have her
career and family in order
pretty much by the time she's 35 because
otherwise the options start to run out
and so that puts a tremendous amount of
stress on women especially at the end of
their 20s i think i take issue with the
idea of the typical woman because you
know all women are different and that's
what i want to just put another quote to
you from the book well they're different
in some ways and the same in others
okay you say women become more
vulnerable when they have children and
you talk to one of your youtube
interviews about crazy harpy sisters
so
simple question is gender equality a
myth in your view is that something
that's just never going to happen
it depends on what you mean by equality
nobody
fairly people we could get to a point
where people were treated fairly or more
fairly i mean people are treated pretty
fairly in western culture already but we
can they're really not though are they i
mean otherwise why would there only be
seven women running ftse 100 companies
in the uk why why would there still be a
pay gap which we've discussed
why are women at the bbc saying that
they're getting paid illegally less than
men to do the same job that's not fair
let's go to the first question they're
both complicated questions seven seven
women repeat that one there's seven
women running the top ftse 100 companies
in the uk well i mean the first question
might be um why would you want to do
that
why would a man want to do it
well there's a lot of money
there's a certain number of of men
although not that many
who are perfectly willing to sacrifice
virtually all of their life to the
pursuit of a high-end career so they'll
work these are men that are very
intelligent they're usually very very
conscientious they're very driven
they're very high energy they're very
healthy and they're willing to work 70
or 80 hours a week non-stop specialized
at one thing to get to the top so you're
saying women are just more sensible they
don't want that because it's not an
isolated i'm saying that's part of it
definitely and so i work
you don't think there are barriers in
their way that prevent them getting to
the top there are some barriers yeah
like other like men for example i mean
to get to the top of any organization is
an incredibly competitive enterprise and
the men that you're competing with are
simply not going to roll over and say
please take the position so let me come
back absolutely is gender equality a
myth
i don't know what you mean by the
question men and women aren't the same
and they won't be the same that doesn't
mean they can't be treated fairly is
gender equality desirable
if it means equality of outcome then
almost certainly it's undesirable that's
already been demonstrated in scandinavia
because in scandinavia i mean by that
equality of outcome is undesirable well
men and women won't sort themselves into
the same categories if you leave them
alone to do it off their own accord i've
already seen that in scandinavia it's 20
to one female nurses to male something
like that it might not be quite that
extreme and approximately the same male
engineers to female engineers and that's
a consequence of the free choice of men
and women in the societies that have
gone farther than any other societies to
make gender equality the purpose of the
law those are inerratical differences
you can eradicate them with tremendous
social pressure and tyranny but if you
leave men and women to make their own
choices you will not get equal outcomes
right so you're
that's interesting the way you break it
down
it changes your view on it
together it's all coming together
because
um i don't know i think growing up like
they always tell women that like that we
have all this stuff against us
but i genuinely don't think we do i
think women have it easier than men
um to an extent it depends what type of
women you are
what do you mean i say like i don't know
we come from different backgrounds right
my background so
um i don't know i did you guys like um a
public school as well i went to a
catholic school
so i feel like they're a bit more strict
over there
maybe yeah i was going to go to a
catholic school but i feel like they
treat the girls
they have the girls have to be a certain
way whereas the boys can be a bit more
free with it
with what catholics will say the girls i
don't know i know with the uniform sorry
just uniform alone like girls have to
wear really long skirts boys can wear
trousers yes but
well i think it's because men and women
are different they are different based
like the boys are allowed to be a bit
more like
right
yeah because i think
how did i put it
a woman's body like guys
are more attracted to than women are to
men's bodies
you don't really see most men you're not
going to be like oh like but but anyone
but a guy sees your body and like that's
they can't really help it
i mean they could but it's just they
don't have behavior
no i don't think so i think like they
can change the they can help their
behavior short but i think a guy's mind
like
yeah you can't
yeah that's just how men are i'll just
say like um so going back to the school
point um
like from an early stage i'm being told
okay maybe you should push towards this
topic because it's better for women so
from young we're being taught like what
topic
like um
i know that with stem so like you know
like engineering
that was more of like i didn't know
about that until my later years of
school
so engineering no one
it was mainly for men and they only like
promoted it to like the little boys and
stuff like that and i didn't know about
literally don't know about engineering
until
i got to like
end of primary school start of secondary
school did you do engineering no i went
to like a convention once but it's like
i couldn't get into it because i was
like
i have to be like really smart for this
and
i'm i can't lie it was a little too late
for me to just start learning about it
but yeah you can become an engineer at
like 18 you can go to school for it
i know but it's like
i feel like i should have started
earlier for that or if it was introduced
to me earlier i would have yeah
well i just i think it's the opposite
they have quotas for engineering you
know what a quote is
so it's um
where they say like we need a certain
amount of women working
you know so so in the name of like
equality they'll say
oh you need to have 50 women at the
company and so they recruit women
regardless of if they're qualified or
not
that's why like they might pick a less
qualified woman over a more qualified
man because they have to fulfill the
quota okay
because they have like no because more
men are interested in engineering like i
i have ten did you have ten siblings
like there's ten of us
and it's funny all the boys are
engineers pretty much yeah all of them
none of the girls like i think girls
just don't really want to do it
like were they not like exposed to it
from a young age either no we grew up in
the same house we were expo we went to
the same school you have like a lot of
brothers that are doing engineering
maybe you should know about it but maybe
i don't know
yeah
well maybe that was the case for you but
i don't think it's the rule
like there's there's girl in there's
like programs called women in stem
there's no men in stem
it's like i was like only introduced
recently so there's only so much that i
can do it's not like an impact that will
but i think i think it's because women
don't want to do it i don't think it's
because they weren't introduced to it
i mean like i think it is like with what
i want to do i want to get into like
sports psychology i found out about this
when i was quite young and so like it
was an interesting topic so i was like
yeah why not yeah because you pursued it
because you were interested like if you
found out about engineering you were
young enough you still could have did it
my brothers didn't do engineering until
they were 18.
yeah like you could be an engineer
yeah but
it's
it's just like i just think women don't
want to do it
i feel like they should at least offer
more programs
they have so many programs i don't know
about any of these programs because like
i like i said i didn't know about stem
until i got to really
yeah if they actually like enforced it
into school then yeah okay people would
have the option to even be in like to
decide if you're interested yeah we'll
keep we'll keep going right so you're
saying that anyone who believes in
equality whether you call them feminists
call them whatever you want to call them
should basically give up because it
ain't going to happen only if they're
aiming at equality of outcome
so you're saying give people equality
of opportunity that's fine it's not only
fine it's eminently desirable for
everyone for individuals and for society
but still women aren't going to make it
that's what you're really saying depends
on your measurement techniques they're
doing just fine in medicine
in fact there are far more female
physicians than there are male
physicians
there are lots of lots of disciplines
that are absolutely dominated by women
many many disciplines and they're doing
great
so let me put something else to you from
the book you say the introduction of the
equal pay for equal work argument
immediately complicates even salary
comparison beyond practicality for one
simple reason who decides what work is
equal it's not possible so the simple
question is do you believe in equal pay
well i made the argument there it's like
it depends so you don't believe in equal
pay
no i'm not saying that at all because a
lot of people listening to you will just
say i mean are we going back to the
doctor you're actually not listening i'm
just looking pretty carefully and i'm
hearing you basically saying women need
to just accept they're never going to
make it on equal terms equal outcomes is
what how you defined it no idea if i was
a young woman watching that i would go
well i might as well just go and play
with my cindy dolls i'd give up trying
at school because i'm not going to get
the top job i want because there's
someone sitting there saying it's not
possible i said that it's horrible it's
going to make you miserable desirable
that's what i said it's a it's a bad
social goal i didn't say that women
shouldn't be striving for the top or
anything like that because i don't
believe that for a second striving for
the top but you're going to put all
those hurdles in their way as has been
in their way for centuries and that's
fine you're saying that's fine no no i
think i really the patriarchal system is
silly i do i think that's silly i really
do i mean look look at your situation
you're hardly unsuccessful yeah and i
have how do you work hard together
exactly
good that's okay battling is good this
is also inevitable but you talk about
men fighting let me just put another
thing to you from the bottom you're
saying you have to battle for a high
quality position
well i notice in your book you talk
about real conversations between men
containing quote and underlying threat
of physicality oh there's no doubt about
that what about real conversations
between women is that something are we
sort of too amenable and reasonable
no it's just that
the domain of physical conflict is sort
of off limits for you well you just said
that i fought to get where i've got yeah
but what does that mean
i don't imagine that you've yeah to some
degree i suspect you're not very
agreeable so that's the thing successful
women i'm not very agreeable right yeah
i've noticed that actually in this
conversation
why can't i i'm not agreeing i believe
sometimes you have to put your foot down
and just be like wait no
she kind of is trying to make him out to
be something he's not i think she's like
attacking him like this is actually
very harsh
is there anything you said so far you
don't agree with
shockingly no
no
why do you think women don't know about
the this
it's not promoted enough
because i actually don't know about this
until like now
do you think that schools
and society pushes us to hate men oh
yeah
yeah
definitely from young
even like in your household it starts
from home and then that's i think that's
how everyone learns it
at home yeah
at home did did your mom teach you that
or your dad or something a bit of both
really like
i don't know my dad was like
he favors my brother more because he's a
boy okay maybe because he's the only boy
and he's like last born so it's like
okay come on there's no competition
but at the same time my mom
she's like someone who babies him and
he's like not allowed to do chores in
the house growing up he wasn't allowed
to do chores in the house
he wasn't really pushed to like
fight for himself in education like he
didn't really care about school sorry
and then with us like the girls so i got
two other sisters we were like pressured
to like know how to cook clean just be a
house that's good
but now my brother is in uni and he's
now my mom's realizing like i think i've
like we have a problem here because
basic like survival needs like cooking
and just
even if he lives by himself he i don't
think he'll know how to manage does he
know how to do traditionally like
masculine things like fix a car change a
oh not even that oh so he just really
um
because he's a boy and
i think that's because he's the last one
as well so not just because he's a boy
but because he's like the baby of the
family have you found that in dating
guys like that you can cook and clean
and like do that type of stuff
it's like a pickup line like oh you
should cook for me sometimes and i'm
thinking
is that like
a way of flirting because i think it's
like
am i a chef or something i'm like a
personal chef i don't really see it as
flatting because that's like no i meant
like guys you're actually dating like
that you date or like on dates with
i mean
not really
oh they don't they don't care i don't
think they care but i can anyways so
it's like they're like okay i've just
found like guys really appreciate it
when like you cook for them yeah
that's a fact yeah like they feel like
it's something special
i think it's because they're seeking
some type of like motherly instinct
within me
no i think i think men like to feel
appreciated and i think that's just one
way women can like appreciate men yeah
but i think we're in a society that like
really doesn't appreciate men like we
kind of
like i always hear girls say things like
i don't need a man
and i always wonder men don't say i
don't need a woman
insoles do oh my days
but i think that's the the equivalent of
an incel is the girls that say i don't
know and there's girls out there that
genuinely hate men and then like
disguise it as feminism that's not
feminism yeah
wilds what do you think in 2022 we're
fighting for in feminism
i feel like everyone's fighting for
something different but like what like
so like this woman i think she's mainly
fighting for the pig up okay um
what am i fighting for
i just wonder i can't think of anything
we can't do in 2022 like especially in
britain we can get abortions up to six
months oh yeah that's good that's pretty
that's pretty i don't believe in
abortion but like for the people that do
so so i so what rights do we do people
in the uk not have
i don't really
necessarily think there's a problem in
the uk okay i could imagine like say
like african countries there's
a serious problem
like um especially because i grew up in
an african home so my parents literally
came from africa
so they still have that mentality and i
have like more of a western mentality so
we clash a lot what do you guys clash
about like
like i said my brother being extremely
lazy i'm like mom he needs to know how
to cook or he's gonna suffer and then
she's like no he's fine
he got into uni this year and she's like
you know your brother's like really lazy
and i'm just sitting there like
okay what should i do about it like
you've raised him to be that way maybe
if he if he raised us equally
he wouldn't be struggling the way he is
but yeah i don't think the uk is it's
there's not much of a problem in the uk
it's more like other countries so what
what else do you guys clash on other
than your brother being lazy
i wasn't allowed to go partying my
brother was
and that's good
i think we should both stay at home he's
like he chooses to stay at home though
yeah
well i i agree
and you still stay at home and i'm just
not allowed to go at all well i think
it's true they're just trying to
preserve your value as a woman it's true
my brothers find you as a man to be
preserved as well well
well it sucks but a guy that like sleeps
around gets like and partying is kind of
associated with that but a guy that
sleeps around like it doesn't hurt it
makes him more wanted by women it's a
it's a form of pre-selection
i think
that depends for every person because if
i see a guy and he's always like outside
i think that's unattractive but that's
just me right right what i mean is you
want a guy that other girls want
or you or you want a guy that can get
other girl you want someone that nobody
wants
i actually wouldn't mind
just go for ugly guys because i know
that no one else is going to want them
you know
you know that um
don't you like tall guys i do
okay well
so that's that's a trait that other
girls want yeah is like 80 of women want
20 of men
yeah that's true so
and there's a reason for that it's
pre-selection so what your parents were
doing was trying to because guys don't
want a girl that sleeps around too but
partying doesn't necessarily mean you
sleep around i i agree it doesn't
necessarily mean that but i think most
hookups happen at parties
behaves right i agree like
i i don't think you automatically
that's what it means but
i'd say you're you're more likely to do
that sort of thing if you're always
partying every weekend like no guy wants
to go for a girl that's literally always
drunk
sometimes you like i'd go to parties but
it's not
there's a limit there's actually a limit
yeah sometimes you need to slow down but
i think they were just kind of looking
out for your best interest
yeah
i guess but
still my brother okay i think they were
fine with my brother because he chose
not to go out
so
yeah
okay
at least and i'm sure it served your
career well successful women though
basically have to wear the trousers in
your view they have to sort of become
men to succeed is what you're saying
well if they're i've had to fight to
succeed
against men certainly masculine traits
are going to be helpful i mean one of
the things i do
in in my counseling practice for example
when i'm consulting with women who are
trying to advance their careers is to
teach them how to negotiate and to and
to be able to say no and to not be
easily pushed around and to be
formidable and you need to if you're
going to be successful you need to be
smart conscientious and tough well
here's a radical idea why don't the
bosses adopt some the male bosses shall
we say adopt some female traits so that
women don't have to fight and get their
sharp elbows out for the pay rises it's
just accepted if they're doing the same
job they get the same pay
well i would say partly because it's not
so easy to determine what constitutes
the same job but almost because
arguably yeah there are still men
dominating our industries our society
and therefore they've dictated the terms
for so long that women have to battle to
know that's not true
it's not true so for example
well i can give you an example very
quickly so i worked with women who
worked in high-powered law firms in
canada for about 15 years and they were
as
competent and put together as anybody
you would ever meet and we were trying
to figure out how to further their
careers
and there was a huge debate in canadian
society at that point that was basically
ran along the same lines as your
argument is that if the law firms didn't
use these masculine criteria then
perhaps women would do better but the
market sets the damn game it's like and
the market is dominated by men
it's not the market is dominated by
women they make 80 percent of the
consumer decisions that's not the case
at all if you're talking about people
who stay at home looking after children
by and large they are still women so
they're going out doing the shopping but
that is changing they make all right
is driven by women not men right okay
and if you're a lawyer they still pay
more for the same sort of goods
that's been proven that men for the you
buy a blue bicycle helmet is going to
cost less than a pink one anyway we'll
come on to that partly because men are
less agreeable
right so so they won't put up with it i
want to ask you
is it
what is going on
she i don't like the way she's attacking
him
she's rude isn't she
make
i don't think she's the best
representative
for i wouldn't say she's a feminist she
just hates him
no i think she's i think most feminists
are like this is it i i think
i'm not like that but i'm not like most
people i'm
i don't think you're really a feminist i
think you're kind of like i think you
say it because it's politically correct
but i feel like
you agree with too much of the stuff to
be a real feminist
i think people confuse what real
feminism is what she is is kind of
that's radical i think she's confusing
feminism with
like
i don't know what she thinks feminism is
but that's actually just gender equality
like what do you support both men and
women what do you think feminism is
just like
the equality between men and women so
not
like feminists should also support men
okay she's too busy worrying about women
and she feels like men shouldn't be
supported as well
what is equality
equality so just being given like the
same opportunities okay and things like
that would you say we don't have that
it depends on which circumstances
because there's no laws preventing us
from getting any job yeah that's true
so i just like what are we fighting for
i don't really know
i actually don't even know and i know
she's fighting for
not you
well and the other thing you have to
think about there's it's never equal
yeah so it for example if i'm in a
friendship with with someone there's
always a leader and a follower
two people can't lead
and so with men and women and with men
and women there's always a leader and a
follower and usually if the woman's
leaving she hates the guy
like
usually but then is that odd for you
there's a couple yeah there's exceptions
but in general like no girl wants to be
making all the decisions
i could imagine yeah
so i i beg the question like if you're a
feminist what are we fighting for
i'm just fighting i'm just trying to
make sure no one's
trying to put me down because i'm a
woman
okay i haven't been given that i have
been given the opportunity
but i think it was because of
agreeableness like they mentioned
maybe if i fought for myself back then
then i'd probably be um
better
in my career right now
but
other than that
if the opportunity arises i would
probably like that's when i'd become a
full-on feminist
okay
is it not desirable to have some of
those female traits you're talking about
i'd say that's a generalization but
you've used the words female traits is
it not desirable to have some of them at
the top of business i mean maybe they
wouldn't they don't predict that banking
crisis they don't predict success in the
workplace the things that predict
success in the workplace are
intelligence and conscientiousness
agreeableness negatively predicts
success in the workplace so
you're saying that women aren't
intelligent enough to run these topics
no i didn't say that at all he said that
he said female traits don't
he's she is
i like this woman
predict success but i didn't say that
intelligence wasn't i didn't say that
intelligence and conscientiousness well
you were saying female traits just by
implication are not female traits no no
i mean that's very murderous territory
not saying that at all are women less
intelligent than men no no they're not
no the the data on that's pretty clear
the average iq for a woman in the
average iq for a man is identical there
is some debate about the flatness of the
distribution which is something that
james damore pointed out for example in
his memo but there's no difference at
all in general cognitive ability there's
no difference to speak of in
conscientiousness women are a bit more
orderly than men and men are a little
bit more industrious than women but the
difference isn't big i don't think that
averages into controversy any men who
aren't necessarily well of course
why are they not feminine treats why are
they not desirable at the top of
feminine traits why are they not
desirable at the top it's hard to say
i'm just laying out the empirical
evidence like we know that we know the
traits that predict success but we also
know because companies by and large have
not been dominated by women over the
centuries we have nothing to compare it
to
it's an experiment true and it could be
the case that if companies modified
their behavior and became more feminine
they would be successful but there's no
evidence for it i'm not neither doubtful
nor non-doubtful there's no evidence why
not give it a go as the rapture because
the evidence suggests well it's fine if
like if someone wants to start a company
and make it more feminine and
compassionate let's say and caring in
its overall orientation towards its
workers and towards the marketplace then
that's a perfectly reasonable experiment
to run my point is that there is no
evidence that those traits predict
success in the workplace and there's
evidence that's right well that's not
that's not really the case women have
been in the workplace for what at least
ever since i've been around the
representation of women in the workplace
has been about 50 so we've run the
experiment for a fairly reasonable
period of time but not you know
certainly not for centuries let me move
on to another debate that's been very
controversial
she just didn't even
like she'd even say okay fine she just
said okay let's just move on to the next
thing she doesn't want to admit that
she's wrong
yeah and i think the thing i like about
the girls like that i bring on here is a
lot of you guys are very open to new
ideas and be like changing your opinion
minded feminism that's oh please oh my
gosh you have to be open-minded if
you're trying to excel in life yeah
and
she
it's like even if she has the facts
evidence data and statistics in front of
her she's going to believe what she
believes regardless
yeah and what do you think that he about
what he was just saying
about um like feminine traits yeah i
kind of agree with that well not
necessarily feminine traits but it's
just traits that females tend to adopt
yeah society is it as if it's feminine
but
a girl can still possess
masculine traits and a geiger still
possess feminine traits but
she's just saying
i think she's trying to say that he's
still generalizing and he's not he's
just i can't really describe it do you
think that generalizing is always bad
um
most of the time yes
why
because there's always that
there's like that small percentage that
isn't part of that but don't you think
as adults we kind of understand that
there's exceptions yeah
some people refuse to like
identify that that there are exceptions
like if i said i wanted him
like if i said women don't like to work
as long as hours
it and i i work a lot i work i'm work
anyone that knows me personally
so i wouldn't consider myself in that
group
but
i think
that most people understand what i'm
saying
and it's the people looking to be
offended that are like well what about
what about that one
yeah and clearly and so i think as
adults we can have a conversation about
different groups
because how else are then then you can't
group anyone together
nobody
it's just some people there's always
going to be someone that's like upset
yeah
they want a reason to be upset yeah okay
very controversial for you um
and this is you got in trouble for
refusing to call trans men and women by
their preferred personal pronouns
no that's not actually true i got in
trouble because i said i would not
follow the compelled speech dictates of
the federal and provincial government i
actually never got in trouble for not
calling anyone anything right that
didn't happen you wouldn't follow the
change of law which was designed not
once it was discriminated no no
that's all they said it was designed to
do okay you cited freedom of speech in
that why should your right to freedom of
speech
trump a trans person's
right not to be offended
because in order to be able to think you
have to risk being offensive i mean look
at the conversation we're having right
now
you know like you're certainly willing
to risk offending me in the pursuit of
truth why should you have the right to
do that it's been rather uncomfortable
well i'm i'm very glad i put you on this
part
well i'm going to buy this
you get my point it's like you're you're
doing what you should do which is
digging a bit to see what the hell is
going on and that is what you should do
but you're exercising your freedom of
speech to certainly risk offending me
and that's fine i think more power to
you as far as i'm concerned
except you haven't sat there and
i'm just right i'm just trying to work
that out i mean
ha gotcha you have got me you have got
me i'm trying to work that through my
head yeah yeah it took a while took a
while yeah
i can see what he's trying to say now
but he just chose the wrong time to
bring up the fact that
like this whole freedom of switching he
chose the wrong time to bring you up
like she brought it up no i mean like
when he said made those comments
saying about he doesn't want to follow a
law that stops him from saying like what
he wants to say
but people are just offended of the fact
that he said it in a time where they're
trying to make it illegal
to
misgender trans people
so i don't think he wants to misgender
trans people it's just that he wants to
speak freely but he just chose the wrong
time to speak about that why is it the
wrong time if that's the time when the
law is being introduced
wouldn't that be the right time
i mean there's ways to word it
like
how do i say it could be the right time
but
it was like pictures as if he doesn't
want to
[Music]
identify them as what they want to be
identified as
how
can you communicate that without being
offending people um
it seems like any way that he would
communicate that would offend them okay
like i said everyone would like
someone's always going to be offended
yeah maybe he could say like
i probably do i did like i do call them
what they want to be addressed as
but i feel like people should
be allowed to express themselves he does
say that but people just still take it
that way
yeah that's always going to be a bad
person yeah and that's that's the
problem with like
the media is they just take things out
of context media
the power of the media is crazy it's
really crazy isn't it
um i'm gonna end the video there
but
what are your final thoughts
on like what do you think of jordan
peterson would you watch him again
i would yeah because i don't think i he
said anything mad
like
he actually backed up all his points and
he was able to break it down
to so that it made sense but that woman
was just making it difficult for him
have any of these points made you think
differently
um
so going back to like what happened the
other day yes i see like the difference
between the playground but
right now
not really not really okay
it um
and you still don't know what we're
fighting for for feminism because it's
like there's so many different causes so
it's just like pay gap um
say for example
like
i don't even want to get controversial
but this this channel is controversial
that's what i do
um
like one thing i'm passionate about is
that you know like rape victims
yeah stuff like that one thing i hate is
people who lie about rape because it's
bad on bad for the men as well yeah but
they don't want to talk about that
but i feel like they should focus both
on the actual victims of rape and the
men who have been lied to and men who
have also been raped
so yeah they need to focus on that okay
how would they focus on it because it's
already it's illegal right it's illegal
but
how do like do people get penalized for
lying about rape i don't know actually
that's probably something i would agree
with you on that there should be harsher
punishments
because like even with the amber herd
johnny de like that's come like there's
going to be more i bet i guarantee
there's going to be more people men that
come forward
yeah it's not like
it's me it's made to seem as if it's bad
for a man to experience these things
like even domestic abuse they're not
allowed to come sorry they're not
allowed to come forward even she was
screaming like yeah go tell the world
that i johnny depp a man is a victim of
domestic abuse like he's being shamed
for it so obviously he's not going to
feel like he should come forward it's
not a safe space for him but i feel like
there should be more safe spaces for men
as well okay yeah i would agree with you
on that but i don't think feminism in
general promotes that
feminism i think they caused it
they said believe all women
[Music]
um that's no that was you're a bit young
okay
so when i was your age
that was
that was the norm
believe all women was plastered
everywhere
out all everyone that was a feminist was
was
women as in like
facebook posts were written about men
like by everybody saying their
experience was great right and
you there there's just no way
like like some some girls had to be
lying yeah they're like like because
they're shitty women shitty men right
and so but at that time you could that's
that's why amber heard got away with it
because she wrote an op-ed with no
evidence against johnny depp
so
she
like
essentially ruined his career by just
coming forward i blame feminism for that
because they that was their movement
believe it wasn't just the radical ones
it was everybody
i could okay that's probably back in the
day i'm more of like a recent one yeah i
think they do it again i think has
changed i don't think so i don't because
they still promote the pay gap and
there's no way that the people in charge
don't know that this isn't real if
you're if you're promoting a stat over
and over again a public platform you
don't think anyone
brought it up to them that there's
different reasons for the pay gap so why
are you still promoting it it doesn't
make sense it depends on what every
feminist promotes
i think most
i think either i do think there's a lot
of people like like you right but i
don't think you're really like with
there's no i no there's not
i think most of them are nuts
like most of the girls like i would love
to get some of the crazy ones on here
but they don't they don't want to come
i feel like there will be a fight in
here so
bring them to me bring them
um okay well thank you so much for
coming on i really appreciate having
conversations with people that i might
not agree with so i think these are
really good especially when they're
constructive and it's not like an
argument yeah i prefer debates over
arguments because arguments are yeah
no they don't
um i
hope you enjoyed the video let them let
them know where they can find you um
instagram again at the line q301
but yeah it's just that for now
okay guys um don't forget to subscribe
to the channel like this video if you've
watched two or more of my videos and you
don't subscribe we have beef okay
for real beef
it's not cool
um okay also y'all i'm turning i'm doing
memberships soon i'm turning off my
members i'm turning my chats onto
members only quite soon so enjoy it
won't last sign up for my memberships
don't forget to subscribe i will talk to
you guys next time